you just celebrated your daughter's
graduation that's amazing so are you and
katherine
ready to be empty nesters um
yeah i i think so i mean
we had a lovely experience it was a
virtual graduation we couldn't actually
be in the same room that she was
in um because of covert
protections and all of that and i was so
wonderful i'm so proud of her
but i got to tell you kelly it's a
little rough and you're going out the
doors and the other parents
are saying oh congratulations say thank
you congratulations to you
i said you must be so proud of your
granddaughter
i said well
i don't know man i i i don't know yeah
okay
i'm not gonna take it personal you know
i thought they're just trying to be nice
but uh yeah we had you know we we we
were we were getting ready for it
uh and we prepared but then when uh when
the covet happened and we had everybody
back home
uh this past year yeah but there is that
moment
you know uh when you when they're gone
and they're out of the house and they're
gone and you look at each other
and in the back of your mind thinking
what are we going to talk about
what are we doing you get to date again
you get to date people well you do well
yeah you can do all that but you really
you as a marriage you so much of your
time evolves when i'm talking about your
kids
you know what they're doing how are they
doing and this and that's an easy
conversation
so uh i think we're going to do real
well we're we we got our
our suitcases packed uh the kobe is
getting down we're looking to do a lot
of traveling in the next couple of years
moving around
i'm going to be working over here in
europe for a lot of this next year so
wow we'll be okay that's exciting i know
i always love that i think you get to
start dating again i think that's fun
want more fun stuff i thought so check
out these videos floating around my head
this one is really cool i'm just saying
no pressure